secret j'ai deux au point de vue vous
voulez toucher de son pointu ouais ouais
ouais est touchée
102 au point ils sont tous tes joues
pour tous sapé matin doit annoncer
à papeete je connais c'est incroyable ce
qu'on peut faire c'est crade sur
secret moi j'ai déjà fait fermer un
hôtel de luxe 5 pour moi au mixer non
match était en vacances dans un palace
et un jour ils ont fait une annonce dans
un hôtel ils ont dit on ferme tout le
thème tout la piscine c'est un enfant
qui est dans la piscine non en fait
c'était pas l'enfoncer témoin non
le problème
devient
vite
prenez le week-end avait franchement
quelque chose si les nazis faire mais je
suis disponible à l'écouté sur
votre
mobile non merci
benjamin benjamin aussi voilà moi j'ai
un secret incroyable allez-y c'est quoi
à l'âge de 7 ans a échappé à la mort non
c'est pas vrai c'est con ça
pour ça il ya toutes ces experts qui
font plus d'argent n'est pas ça
franchement on aurait peut être ton
qu'il court voyage a eu d'abord qu'il a
eu en fait j'ai les jeux dans une
carrière de sable barrette a pas vu un
élan et en fait je faisais des tunnels
ont l'art et d'études m je creusais
comme ça j'avais à le blé le bras dans
le plâtre ah ouais et quand je chantais
déjà très content
je suis rentré à la maison ma grand mère
j'ai fait comme ça le sable est tombé
par terre me lequel que c'est que ce
samedi pas je vais jouer dans une
carrière minutes interdit d'y retourner
et tous les amis avec qui j'étais il se
retourne et l'après midi et tout s'est
effondré sont tous morts
je ne serais jamais venu me touche pas
je vous le jure sa tête de tous les
enfants et bien la carrière wez macquart
et aux cinq fois ses rivaux j'ai planté
mais
raconter ça va mais jacques auger croit
pas je vois alors chez reed
série doc c'est pourquoi je vous vous
éclairer
[ __ ] m bon on n'a pas un truc sympa
un officier lui
windchill hier et hier ayant resto j'ai
vu delphine ernotte la présidence de
france télévisions ali déjeuner avec
marc olivier fogiel ah ouais c'est tout
ça très intéressant ah oui oui oui quand
même oui oui tina oui parce que la
serbie se libère et oui c'était pas mal
et puis et puis j'étais chez flunch
dit chez flunch non mais on va plaçe
manger léger mange équilibré ça la fout
khrouchtchev je
[Applaudissements]
me suis toujours sentie terriblement
belle emma qu'elle allait enregistrer
cette pub il arrivait carte sim et
hellcats de retourner
[Rires]
statu
quo patrick dumoulin chien s'est plainte
chez flunch commun alors combien nous
coûte
2,99
après tcheky manger léger qui
visiblement ne cherchons coûte état de
0,99 on va plonger
c'est bon c'est dans la boîte et nous en
refaire une akotègnon
sans déconner ça va être magnifique
j'adore c'était important tandis que
vous avez un secret digne de dwight
story oui c'est un secret à à un vrai
j'ai un secret oui alors c'est quoi je
peux pas dire un secret mais ce qu'elle
ne vous dérobez pas alors oui je vous
dire la vérité j'ai un secret
j'ai les couilles bleus et
je vais vous le prouver regardez
à regarder
[Applaudissements]
mais reconnaît oui bon je ne pensais pas
qu'on allait parler ça j'étudie j'ai
tout mon stock voilà non c'est un animal
c'est un an glissant c'est parce que je
regardais des trucs comme ça et je suis
tombé sur le vrd mais à quel moment vous
vous croirez comme ça par hasard je tape
sur google coolblue
alors au départ
et puis après je tombais sur ce gars
très sympa d'ailleurs au début mais pas
la tranquille il est comme ça tranquille
dans la forêt
comme as les couilles but on voit comme
un saint